[Musique]
bien raison débat sur France 24
largement consacré à l'interview de
Macron dans Le Parisien Aujourd'hui en
France le président français qui se
confier aux lecteurs du journal pendant
plus de 2h cette interview a suscité un
tollé de toutes les oppositions en
raison des propos des Macron contre les
non vacciné les non vacciné j'ai très
envie de les emmerder et donc on va
continuer de le faire jusqu'au bout et
c'est ça la stratégie à d'Emmanuel
Macron quand ma liberté viens menaces et
celle des autres je deviens un
irresponsable un irresponsable n'est
plus un citoyen alors dérapage ou
calcule ses propos sont-ils révélateurs
d'un président candidats un candidat en
face aux extrêmes ce n'est pas une
entrée en campagne officielle d'Emmanuel
Macron mais il a envie a-t-il affirmé
des propos tenus vous le savez sur fond
de crise sanitaire de débat houleux à
l'Assemblée nationale sur le fameux
vaccinal alors se passe vaccinal
sera-t-il adopter le 15 janvier comme
prévu on évoquera aussi ce qui est
Emmanuel Macron dit sur le poids qu'il
en coûte et sur et on va en parler donc
tout de suite dans le débat avec
Roselyne Febvre qui m'a rejoint sur ce
pet au chef du service politique de
France 24 Bonsoir Roselyne
donc en Skype Jean-Baptiste Moreau
député la République en marche de la
Creuse Bonsoir à vous et bienvenue
bonsoir merci nous avons également avec
nous Othman nasrou porte-parole de
Valérie Pécresse vice-président de la
région Île-de-France Bonsoir à vous et
bienvenue également dans le débat
Merci de votre invitation et puis en
duplex de Bruxelles nous avons avec nous
Younous Omarjee eurodéputé la France
insoumise Bonsoir à vous et bienvenue
également
Bonsoir alors les propos de mail Macron
la vue en susciter des réactions outrée
de l'ensemble de l'opposition je vous en
propose un florilège
l'insulte n'est jamais la bonne solution
oui il faudra mettre fin à ce
quinquennat du mépris je veux y mettre
fin je suis d'ailleurs la seule à
pouvoir en terminer avec un président
qui visiblement ne supporte plus les
Français quand il ne pense pas comme lui
référendum pour ou contre Macron
ils ont fait un plébiscite ça c'est une
faute politique en plus de la crise
politique
qui se permet qui se permet de
d'insulter une partie des Français en
les traitant de non citoyen et tu dis
responsable ça n'est pas de la franchise
c'est de la violence or le président est
le garant de la cohésion nationale
aujourd'hui il est le promoteur de la
division nationale
écouter pour compléter le porte-parole
Gabriel Attal porte-parole du
gouvernement c'était cet après-midi lors
d'une conférence de presse qui emmerde
la vie de qui aujourd'hui
qui gâche la vie de nos soignants qui
depuis 2 ans sont mobilisés sous l'eau
dans notre service de réanimation pour
sauver des patients qui aujourd'hui sont
essentiellement non vacciné ce sont ceux
qui s'opposent au vaccin et je vais vous
dire que les propos du président de la
République me semble très en deux ça de
la colère d'une très grande majorité des
Français face à ce choix qui est fait de
s'opposer au vaccin
Mozinor soutiens totalement bien sûr du
côté Gabriel Attal du côté de Jean
Castex également qui s'est exprimé dans
l'hémicycle cet après-midi la République
en marche est-ce que c'est un dérapage
ou un calcul de la part des mails Macron
non plutôt un calcul politique ou alors
si c'est un dérapage dérapage ce qu'on
appelle contrôler Emmanuel Macron a
donné cette interview ce n'est pas c'est
pas sur le feu de l'action on va dire
c'est préparé il est français d'un panel
de français du journal Le Parisien qui
l'entoure là ça dure 2h et puis il faut
savoir que les journalistes souvent en
presse écrite sont soumis à la relecture
et parfois les disais relis et là
visiblement il y a eu aucune aucun
contrat donc voilà les avais une tête et
à mon avis c'est un c'est un calcul
politique notamment le sujet sanitaire
parce qu'il sait que dans aujourd'hui il
est le chef de la crise sanitaire il
sait que des Français se tourne vers lui
il sait que la majorité lance elles sont
vaccinés il reste que 5 million de de
réfractaire et il a la majorité on va
dire des Français de son côté ce que
peut pêcher en tout cas c'est la forme
la forme c'est que il y a 3 semaines il
nous expliquer quand même son mea-culpa
sur les petites phrases les mots qui
blessent interview sur TF1 voilà
exactement et aujourd'hui ben il remet
un peu ça il se sert de la phrase de
Pompidou qu'il qu'il remet un peu
on va dire en disant il faut vous avez
Pompidou disais il faut arrêtez
d'emmerder les Français
donc il se sert de cette phrase pour
frapper fort et pour faire de la
provocation et date d'une certaine
manière dans la radicalité mais il le
fait exprès il le fait exprès la phrase
en revanche qui a choqué plus que on va
emmerder les les antivax c'est et vous
l'avez rappeler une
quand on est irresponsable on n'est plus
si toi ça c'est la phrase de trop
Haussmann
vous a plu porte-parole l'un des portes
pas oui portable de Valérie Pécresse Val
et pl
indigné l'insulte mais jamais à la bonne
solution Éric Ciotti d'ailleurs adresser
donc un des soutiens bien sûr de Valérie
Pécresse à comparer justement cette
phrase que je viens de citer Rosine
d'ailleurs avec la déchéance de
nationalité pour les terroristes vous
êtes d'accord ça va aussi loin que cela
un président de la République devrait
pas dire ça un président de la
République il est là pour rassembler les
Français il est là pour servir tous les
Français et quel que soit ce qu'ils
pensent des non vacciné il ne peut pas
s'exprimer en 7 termes qui ne font pas
seulement pas avancer le sujet qui sont
enregistre en plus grossier qui abîme la
stature présidentielle et en plus on
peut pas commencer à considérer qu'il y
a des citoyens de seconde catégorie C
sont des propos de totalement indigne et
en plus je pense qu'ils sont en train d'
un grand cynisme puisque ça a été
rappeler à l'instant il y a 3 semaines
nous expliquer que désormais il aimait
les Français qu'il arrêtait les petites
phrases et je vois que 3 semaines plus
tard peut-être la perspective de voir sa
réélection lui échapper fait qu'il
choisit de qilive et des bas de mettre
de l'huile sur le feu et je crois que il
démontre ainsi qu'il n'est pas le
président de la République dans le pays
a besoin mais peut-être tout simplement
déjà candidats sont vraiment le dire
Jean-Baptiste Moreau en tout cas on peut
voir qu'il a réussi à réunir toutes les
oppositions contre lui avec ses
déclarations avec ses propos Emmanuel
Macron Loris justement n'est-il pas
attiser encore les violences les
clivages est-ce que ce n'est pas
contradictoire avec ce qu'il a dit aussi
dans cette interview où il a dit qu'il
fallait combattre la montée des excès en
mettant plus de raison dans le débat
collectif et moins de passions négatives
as qu'à pas une contradiction véritable
la
droite et la gauche
pour
faire de la politique politicienne
un peu trop moi c'est c'est c'est rien
du tout par rapport à ce que j'entends
que ce soit des soignants de la
population sur mon territoire et
notamment des soignants à l'hôpital
public sur la façon dont les tresses en
plus parfois certains antivax qui
viennent les insulter jusque devant
l'hôpital ou même parfois jusqu'à leur
domicile donc voilà il y a une
proportion de la population j'ai entendu
depuis hier il faut convaincre oui ça
fait un an qu'on essaie de convaincre et
ça a marché la preuve au départ on avait
plus de 50 % des Français qui ne
souhaitez pas se faire vacciner
aujourd'hui on est 90 % France et
vacciné donc la conviction ça a marché
mais vous avez une frange Danti Vax qui
sont pour la plupart manipuler par des
intérêts des espèces de faux
scientifiques qui ont des intérêts
économiques et tordu et qui donc
manipule un certain nombre de personnes
et avec des fausses informations à la
clé cela vous pouvez utiliser tous les
arguments rationnels du monde voulait
qu'on prépare donc c'est vraiment mettre
plus de raison dans le débat comme
justement le dis également le présent tu
dis que de dire qu'on EMMERDE les non
vacciné
oui parce que parce que il porte une
responsabilité dans la charge
aujourd'hui des service de réanimation
donc oui moi ça ne me gêne pas
c'est
qui
va se transformer en fait
il
est pas
là
votre action justement à ses propos
oui je pense que la tempête politique
est à la hauteur de la gravité extrême
des déclarations du président de la
République aussi bien sur la forme que
sur le fond sur la forme il s'est hissé
au niveau d'élégance d'un Donald Trump
et on attend autre chose du président de
la République française je suis
aujourd'hui à Bruxelles et je peux vous
dire que nos partenaires européens au
moment où la France prends d'ailleurs la
présidence du Conseil de l'Union
européenne sont particulièrement étonné
par cette forme d'expression qui ne dit
rien de bon et qui ne fait pas honneur à
notre pays mais le plus grave et
ailleurs et le plus grave et sur le fond
et dis une conception en réalité
autoritaire du président Macron parce
que et je veux vous lire l'article 5 de
la Déclaration des droits de l'homme et
du citoyen qui dit rapidement tout ce
qui n'est pas défendu pas oui c'est très
court tout ce qui n'est pas défendu par
la loi ne peut-être empêcher est nul ne
peut être contraint à faire ce qu'elle
n'ordonne pas la réalité c'est que le
gouvernement n'a pas fait le choix de la
vaccination obligatoire et il y a la
liberté quand on peut considérer
évidemment qu'il faut convaincre pour se
faire vacciner mais il y a la liberté de
citoyens de ne pas se faire vacciner et
cela ne peuvent pas être déchu de leur
citoyenneté et je crois que ce qui est
encore plus grave dans les déclarations
du président de la République c'est que
au fond il instaure deux catégories de
citoyens
bon citoyen et les mauvais citoyen ceux
qui ont les bons comportements et les
mauvais comportement et cela nous
rappelle en réalité la situation dans
des pays très autoritaire c'est le moins
que l'on puisse dire comme la Chine où
on fait la chasse aux comportements
déviants et on note des citoyens en
fonction de leur niveau de CIVIS et bien
je crois que c'est l'entrée en campagne
d'un président très autoritaire et c'est
bien cela qui sera je crois aussi au
cœur de la campagne de qui s'ouvre des
prises il accompagne la campagne à
Clermont ouverte Jean-Baptiste Moreau
vous répondez peut-être justement à ce
que tu viens de dire Younous Omarjee sur
le côté autoritaire du président sur
l'image de la France effectivement on en
parle à Bruxelles de cette expression
d'ailleurs même les Anglo-Saxons et se
trouver une bonne traduction pour le mot
emmerder
oui oui
mais je veux pas faire la connaissance
pour
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
école pour qu'un enfant puisse rentrer à
l'école ça c'est simple mais un adulte
ou lui demander où à l'entrée de
l'entreprise quand il sort dans la rue
la vieille dame qui est isolé dans son
village et qui ne va pas au restaurant
qui voit très peu de personnes dans la
journée vous allez la chercher chez elle
est en prison volume était une amende si
elle est si l'obligation vaccinale ou
alors vous mettez pas de sanction en ce
moment là c'est pas une robe à
l'Allemagne va adopter une obligation
vaccinale dans un mois et l'Autriche est
également sur le point de le faire donc
c'est aussi possible
parce que
ça veut dire que
ça veut dire que tout et tout et tout
est obligatoirement être
la grande distribution
supermarchés aux courses alimentaires de
première nécessité si vous avez une
obligation vaccinale vous ne pourrais
même pas y aller je veux dire
de prendre une amende dis-moi si vous
êtes contrôler par les forces de l'ordre
dans la rue ou à l'entrée du magasin
Roselyne Geoffrey intervenir juste après
un Roselyne un petit mot justement pour
l'accompagner lancer clairement donc ça
il y a pas officiellement dit qu'il
était candidat mails Macron mais il y a
dit tout de même qu'il n'y a pas de
souci de faux suspense j'ai envie oui il
y a 2 ans vit à la première emmerder les
Français et envie d'être candidat donc
décidément on est dans les envies
d'Emmanuel Macron oui pardon si
on peut se demander s'il y a une forme
d'impulsivité chez Emmanuel Macron parce
que je disais tout à l'heure il y a ce
désir en tout cas de transgresser sur le
terrain de la santé puisque il est en
terrain on va dire sécurisé et puisqu'il
a un bon socle de bonne opinion de
opinion donc c'est le seul moment où il
peut un peu transgresser
la tension
faire de la radicalité en quelque sorte
comme Éric Zemmour peut le faire par
exemple mais pourquoi on distingue ré
président est candidat à ce moment-là
lorsque il disait des petites phrases
aussi il y a 6 mois un an on aurait pas
dit au qu'on distinguait du qui qui fait
ça pour te faire remarquer
parce qu'il a tout intérêt parce qu'on
va lui reprocher de faire campagne avec
les moyens donc comme tous les
présidents le reproche le lui sera fait
donc sont intéressés se déclarer au plus
tard comme l'a fait François Mitterrand
et aussi Nicolas Sarkozy donc voilà mais
ça fait quoi mois de février après
l'aurais mars au 7 février alors là
c'est vrai que ça se complique un peu et
puis quand même alors on a pas la
dépêche AFP qui nous dit Emmanuel Macron
a dit qu'il était candidat enfin on a
compris que c'était il y avait pas de
suspens et qui est bien évidemment il
serait candidats de regarde les tous
derniers il fait toujours la course en
tête avec Valérie Pécresse Marine Le Pen
qui sont au coude-à-coude il y a
également Éric Zemmour et Jean-Luc
Mélenchon donc qui est en tête des
forces de gauche mais à peu près avec un
9 pourcents Othman nasrou il y a en ce
moment donc c'est discussion qui
poursuivent sur le Pass vaccinal qui est
venu donc on voit un enjeu presque
partisans puisque en plus sans réponse
ça on voit qu'il est bien en tout cas
sont très houleux au sein de l'Assemblée
nationale que Jean Castex a dû se
présenter aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous allez le voter se passe
vaccinal combien de Heller vont-ils le
voter véritablement
je vous répondre juste avant parce que
dans cette affaire il faut distinguer la
forme et le fond la forme encore une
fois il faut le redire je suis surpris
d'un partie qui est la République en
marche et la prison de la République
inacceptable
une expression
une insulte
je comprends que vous soyez obligé de
vous montrer mais sur la forme c'est
totalement inacceptable
puisque vous m'interroger sur le Pass
vaccinal nous avons toujours été
extrêmement claire parce que on veut
faire croire d'abord nous sommes
favorables à la vaccination c'est un
outil indispensable à toi ou pas
aujourd'hui
vous allez le voter
se passe vaccinal pour la raison simple
que nous n'avons que nous sommes
aujourd'hui au pied du mur à cause de la
mauvaise gouvernement en réalité ce qui
emmerde les Français pardon de reprendre
du président de la République mais
puisque visiblement peut s'exprimer
ainsi ce qu'ils ont merde aussi c'est la
mauvaise gestion de crise cette fête qui
n'est toujours pas de l'idée l'animal
sont supplémentaires il y en a même moi
contrairement à ce qui avait été annoncé
au début de la crise il y a bientôt 2
ans c'est que le protocole sanitaire à
l'école ils sont annoncés le dimanche
soir pour le lundi matin c'est que
encore une fois tous les députés n'étais
pas là le
avant-hier au soir à minuit au moment où
tu es pas là mais vous vous êtes
débrouillés aussi pour suspends pour que
les débats soit suspendu ça c'est
effectivement aussi je verrai la faute
du député en aucun cas si la majorité
n'est pas suffisamment présente il est
ça que ça s'arrête parce que le
gouvernement sera mis en minorité alors
que normalement il a la majorité sur les
députés de la République en marche qui
sont pourtant plusieurs centaines qui
n'ont pas jugé être présent pour le
premier texte de l'année un texto c'est
important donc c'est son d'inverser les
rôles vous êtes aux responsabilités et
assumer les et c'est pas on a demandé
contre-feu avec cette déclaration
fracassante du président de la
République
le vrai sujet qui est aujourd'hui encore
une fois c'était sur le sujet dans cette
gestion de la crise sanitaire en parler
bisous on pourrait parler de beaucoup de
sujets aujourd'hui effectivement essaie
de mettre sous le tapis est content et
après faire insulter une partie des
Français ce qui ne fait absolument pas
avancer le sujet et ce n'est pas avec ça
qu'on va faire des vacciner
supplémentaires et donc aujourd'hui nous
en responsabilité nous nous poserons pas
se passe vaccinal mais nous continuons à
souligner tous les manquements de ce
gouvernement dans la gestion de ses
crises sanitaires est-ce que vous pensez
que vous allez pouvoir tenir le délai du
15 janvier sur ce fameux passe vaccinal
avec se débat houleux à l'Assemblée et
tout ce qui se passe vous m'entendez
pas s'opposer à se passe mal parce que
il faudra dire parle de madame qui a
voté un amendement de suppression du
Pass vaccinal dans l'article faudra lui
expliquer que il doit pas se poser mais
bref je reviendrai pas sur sur la
politique et le politique qu'à essayer
de faire les cons essayer de faire les
LR le premier soir où on les a pas vu de
la soirée j'ai invité
parfaitement regarder les images
il n'y était pas
[Musique]
France insoumise vous allez voter contre
se passe vaccinale la France insoumise
oui je vous remercie de me donner la
parole je veux dire que je suis à
Bruxelles en duplex et que je ne peux
pas intervenir dans dans le débat oui
c'est vrai
qui s'oppose au pas vaccinal en France
absolument la deuxième chose je n'ai pas
l'intention de polémiquer avec mes
collègues et en particulier le collègue
de la République en marche mais je pense
qu'il serait bon de faire baisser la
tension et d'aborder tous ces sujets
avec beaucoup plus de calme et de
respecter les positions des uns et des
autres pour notre part vous l'avez dit
nous sommes opposés totalement opposé à
se passe vaccinal qui ne règle rien et
vous le reverrez qui ne réglera rien
depuis 2 ans c'est l'un préparation en
tout est la situation ne cesse de
s'aggraver nous avons fait des positions
que nous avons mis sur la table je pense
que d'abord nous devons aussi penser à
faire en sorte que les brevets de
vaccins soient lever pour qu'on puisse
véritablement faire en sorte qu'elle
échelle globale on puisse également
avancer dans la lutte contre l'épidémie
autrement fatalement elle finira par
rebondir chez nous et bien sûr comme
notre notre collègue DLR Lady vous avez
eu quand même une baisse significative
du nombre de lits beaucoup de Lyon était
fermée et compris pendant la crise
épidémique ce que nous disons
aujourd'hui par exemple une mesure tout
simple donner gratuitement des masques
FFP2 pourquoi ne le fais ton pas le
gouvernement se refuse à le faire donc
il y a une un préparation il y a
toujours des solutions
punitive des punitions collectives
qu'ils ont réalité à graver les tensions
à graver les fractures dans le pays et
on ne peut pas gouverner
avec la peur et une volonté de mettre
tout le monde au pas à l'ordre du
président de la République
les Français lui-même l'a dit d'ailleurs
d'accord en français
tradition d'une longue tradition
réfractaire et il n'aime pas ce type de
comportement Jean-Baptiste vous répond
justement sur ses FFP2 peut-être que
c'est une question assez intéressant et
on les voit très peu en France
finalement ils sont pas distribuer
gratuitement en Allemagne on les voit
partout
[Musique]
et puis
et et
aujourd'hui à l'heure actuelle que la
vaccination qui permet d'éviter de
mourir du covit de façon très clair
c'est trouver trouver n'y a que ça qui
nous permet d'arriver à éviter les cas
graves et donc l'engorgement des
hôpitaux donc les masques FFP2 pourquoi
pas mais moi j'écoute que me disent les
médecins et je mets sur le réserver au
corps médical c'est la décision
politique de la France et
du coup
je ne fais pas partie de ce qu'il faut
augmenter
[Musique]
bien sûr
on connaît
on va dire là là sur la droite sur la
l'orthodoxie budgétaire de la droite
pour qui la bête est importante et on a
le sentiment effectivement Emmanuel
Macron dit on verra ça plus tard et
c'est la fameuse philosophie du quoi
qu'il en coûte mais en tout cas à ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que quand on est à
sa place les autres est-ce qu'il aurait
laissé les entrepreneurs les cafetiers
les hôteliers
perdre leur emploi ne pas avoir de quoi
se nourrir n'y a donc il y a un moment
là la critique est facile l'art est
difficile c'est vrai que ça c'est le
discours de Valérie Pécresse temps de
voir baisser la dépense publique
effectivement le poids qu'il en coûte
finalement vous auriez été au manette
vous me l'auriez pas fait c'est quoi
qu'il en coûte pour soutenir justement
tout le tissu industriel français toutes
les entreprises parce que il y a de la
bête parce que on fait victime en avec
un emprunt
soutenir les entreprises durant la crise
ce n'est pas une chose que nous avons
critiquer et d'ailleurs il n'y a rien de
plus simple que de sortir le
pansement mais le problème c'est que
c'est
ce qui est
de l'avenir et de la fonction publique
sur laquelle on est
le nombre de fonctionnaires
2017 pas du tout c'est
encore une fois
de la retraite avant de vous faire
réagir Jean-Baptiste Moreau parce qu'on
a plus beaucoup de temps je voulais
quand même qu'on parle aussi de Emmanuel
Macron de la France présidente du
Conseil européen puisque c'est le cas
donc depuis le 1er janvier il en a aussi
été question dans cette interview pour
ce que il est revenu bien sûr sur cette
polémique il dit mauvais sur ce fameux
drapeau européen qui qui flottaient sur
l'Arc de Triomphe et puis surtout il a
parlé donc je mens pas de l'armée
européenne cette fois mais de défense
européenne de programme comment face au
grand défi la marine cyber le spatial en
fait on a l'impression si vous voulez
que la France d'Emmanuel Macron est plus
et moins fédéraliste que les Allemands
qui sont carrément favorable à la mise
en place de décision à la majorité par
exemple en politique étrangère ça on
l'entend par Emmanuel Macron
c'est moi vous poser la question
question c'était dans l'interview qui
l'a accordée par
l'extrême droite sur laquelle
on les voit aujourd'hui
ou
pas
et surtout de ne pas le président de la
majorité qualifiée par exemple que les
Allemands sont plus aujourd'hui
je
sais très bien que l'armée commune c'est
un serpent de mer depuis des années qui
sortent en sortant de résistance et pas
forcément celle de la France a d'autres
pays européen donc sur cette présidence
de l'Union française de l'Union
européenne par la France qu'on a pour 6
mois je le rappelle on va déjà avancer
sur des dossiers sur lesquels on
travaille depuis quelques années et
Clément bon notamment le ministre de
l'Agriculture aussi travaille sur le
dossier on a déjà essayé de concrétiser
ses dossiers
sur
justement parce que j'ai une autre
question
encore une fois et il
faut le faire
plusieurs vitesses qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire
[Musique]
s'il y a des gens qui
au niveau européen de marches expliquer
comment fermer les frontières de la
France et grâce à ça on va tout
maîtriser se mentir aux Français c'est
de l'enfumage pure et simple les
questions des migrations notamment avec
les migration climatique qui vont
arriver parce que le changement de
population
et qu'est-ce que ça veut dire des
frontières à l'intérieur de l'Europe
c'est-à-dire qu'on va se mettre d'accord
avec six ou sept pays sur juste commencé
ses migrations et correction des
frontières à l'intérieur de l'Europe
quand justement le président parle d'une
Europe à plusieurs vitesses avantages de
moyens à quelques pays pour contrôler
cette émigration oui peut-être oui et
des accords multilatéraux mais pas
forcément à 27 et peut-être à plusieurs
pour s'entendre sur comment contrôler
l'immigration comment la régule et
comment on gère cette immigration qui va
arriver et migration climatique elle va
arriver alors pour ça des migrations
zéro c'est juste là aussi expliqué qu'on
aura un garçon de marches et d'ailleurs
ça serait d'ailleurs même plus un
problème parce que moi en
circonscription sur mon terrain en
Creuse et plus de d'artisans et de
l'entreprise qui me demander
naturalisation des étrangers
sans-papiers et des papiers pour des
travailleurs qui dois embaucher que des
gens qui ne m'explique qu'il y a trop
d'immigrés sur du département et donc
pas de limitation justement
il
est bien difficile pour moi de
l'organisation de cette émission
le débat est de corriger beaucoup
d'ineptie entendu je suis président
d'une commission parlementaire la
commission du développement régional et
j'aborde cette présidence française
comme un président de commission qui a
travaillé aussi avec la présidence
allemande et la présidence portugaise et
les présidents ce qui ont précédé la
présidence française n'ont pas eu
l'outrecuidance de faire croire que leur
seul pays va révolutionner l'Europe et
va changer l'Europe ça ne se passe pas
comme ça en Europe les décisions sont
prises à 27 et vous avez aussi une autre
institution donc pas de
non c'est pas ce que je dis non il faut
faire aussi
il est évident que je crois c'est ma
position personnel qu'il faut une robe à
27 et non pas à plusieurs vitesses en
tout cas tout faire trouver les
solutions dans ce cadre nous avons déjà
et je veux dire que la France commence
assez mal cette présidence française
puisque nous avons proposé une taxonomie
sur les énergies et les énergie de
transition en intégrant aujourd'hui le
gaz et le nucléaire ce qui est en
contradiction avec les grandes
orientations du Green New Deal européen
qui est la vision stratégique porter
d'ailleurs par la présidente de la
commission Ursula von der Leyen donc je
ne crois pas que ce soit une très bonne
manière pour rentrer dans cette
présidence française et d'ailleurs le
lobbying la France a fait pour vous
voulez dire
oui et je vous parle de la taxonomie
s'agissant de la migration et bien
évidemment nous voyons les
positionnement habituel mais nous sommes
dans une situation où vous avez une
révolution démographique à l'échelle
mondiale vous avez un continent européen
qui a qui est confronté à des zones de
plus en plus des peuples et je vous
prends un pays comme l'Allemagne d'ici
2100 l'Allemagne va voir sa population
diminuer le Portugal diminuer par deux
pour l'Espagne les chiffres sont
également très
inquiétant et donc dans ce contexte là
dans ce contexte cela il faut aborder la
question de la migration totalement
différemment puisque la possibilité de
migration c'est aussi la possibilité de
la continuation de la croissance en
Europe ce n'est pas moi qui le dis
les études qui sont fait comme il faut
gérer une gestion européenne européenne
qui sont fait par l'ONU donc il faut une
gestion européenne et il ne faut pas
sombrer devant les discours aujourd'hui
nationaliste et les discours d'exclusion
de l'extrême droite en Europe et qui
sont en plus des discours nationaliste
très identitaire qui conduisent en
définitive a refusé tous les échanges
l'Europe le continent européen a
toujours été en continent sur lequel
l'échange se fait et si nous rentrons
dans cette vision d'une Europe
forteresse dans ce contexte global
l'Europe finira par mourir c'est aussi
simple que cela
distance et regarder les choses avec
beaucoup plus
coup plus de sérénité en réalité
vous pouvez répondre sur cette question
de l'Europe des migrations de Schengen
il faut la faire à 27 est-ce qu'il faut
faire ça te rend pas plusieurs vitesses
d'en parler mais le Macron dans une
interview
il faut la faire avec ce qu'ils veulent
la faire avec nous 27 si c'est possible
et nous nous sommes attachés évidemment
la protection des frontières de l'Europe
une robe qui protège c'est ce que défend
à Valérie Pécresse et je m'amuse de voir
le président de la République reprendre
c'était parce que quand on est déformé
pendant longtemps on a été souvent avec
critiquer la droite la droite
républicaine pour avoir une approche
et
je ne reconnais pas ce que
aujourd'hui il faut voir
avec lui
Macron vous explique aujourd'hui qu'il
va faire ce que Emmanuel n'a pas fait
pendant 5 ans et donc moi je veux bien
on sortait encore une fois des thèmes et
des concepts comme l'Europe à plusieurs
vitesses la réalité aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il n'a pas su leadership et il ne l'a
pas parce que la politique intérieure du
pays ne lui donne pas un exemple pour le
reste de l'Europe fort que nous avons le
record de la déesse le record de déficit
il comprit de la balance commerciale
c'est difficile pour lui d'entraîner
l'Europe de résolution il prétend
proposé ça explique pourquoi enfin quand
nous n'avons pas eu dans notre pays des
réformes importante notamment sur ce
sujet là de la maîtrise
aujourd'hui merci
Rosine une petite conclusion justement
sur Macron Emmanuel Macron président du
Conseil européen ça va pas être simple
de pouvoir gérer justement cette
présidence européen à côté est la
compagne de l'autre
si je pense que ici est préparé depuis
longtemps et il va essayer de se glisser
dans
quel est le nouveau chancelier allemand
qui est pas encore ses chaussons de
profiter branche pour imposer en tout
cas ce qu'il veut c'est-à-dire une robe
puissante et souverain ce qu'il a
martelé tout au long de la crise à dire
que l'Europe retrouve sa souveraineté
notamment en matière
on a vu de médicaments par exemple donc
ça c'est c'est c'est ce que lors de la
vision des d'Emmanuel Macron et il va
tout à fait à mon avis avec qui tu es de
cette tâche qu'il voilà le sais depuis
longtemps c'est même pas pour ça que ça
va l'aider à être réélu en tout cas ça
va être pour lui voilà une un costume de
plus une casquette de plus dans un
costume trois-pièces ce sera la
troisième pièce de son costume merci
Roseline merci beaucoup Jean-Baptiste
d'avoir été avec nos députés la
République en marche merci à vous et
merci
à vous tous
[Musique]